oh
[Musique]
on va pas me débarquer le village 200
soir des cistes dans nos portions à nous
de tout et nostalgique quand même de
voir que mon grand père était là qu'est
qui a sûrement explorer ou qui est
sûrement que véhiculent grande histoire
le seulement
simon pierre astor est en innu de
malioténam il est devenu mécanicien de
locomotive à défaut d'être astronaute
comme il le révèle il termine son quart
de travail aux commandes de 3 tonnes
lancé en direction de sept îles la cour
divisée en mille pour se repérer et on
en compte 330 entre sept-îles et chef au
rire tout au long de la voie ferrée
surgissent des camps de chasse souvent
près de la ligne de chemin de fer
autant de petites gares uchiwa tonnes
s'arrête sur demande
quand on vient d'embarquer du monde au
il arrivait justement de leur territoire
et c'est une façon de préserver la
culture
c'est très valorisant de voir ce ont
participé quelque sorte à perpétuer la
culture une autre façon plus moderne
peut-être nous irène transport
ferroviaire c'est justement la société
chez watson qui veut dire le vent du
nord assure le transport entre sept-îles
et schefferville deux fois par semaine
une distance de 530 km dans un
territoire immense où le temps est
dissoute en l'immensité la portion de
200 km entre emeril près de wabush au
labrador et schefferville appartient
depuis 2005 couzinou et ona skate un
train par où transite pratiquement tous
les produits qui sont vendus à
schefferville qu'en l'absence de routes
chaque année ils arrivent par le train à
schefferville 350 wagon de carburant et
350 wagon de nourriture plus de quinze
mille voyageurs dix fois la population
locale empruntent le train dans les deux
directions et de schefferville
il descend plus de deux millions et demi
de tonnes de minerai de fer ces
cocktails mashala le train infernal du
matériel que l'on entend le rénover des
maisons des appartements
à thé cette cour d'un échec les
fournisseurs et d'amener sacha forville
de cette dynamique par georges roy est
en innu élevé en partie à montréal
il gère le vieil hôtel royal un symbole
de chez formule qui nous ramène aux
années 50
le grand père de georges et sa famille
prenait 2 mois à partir de cette île
pour rejoindre leur territoire de
trappes au nord-est de schaeffer ville
un voyage en canot à pied à travers lac
et montagne
si vous êtes une représente maintenant
un outil de développement qui incarne
aussi l'avenir dès le printemps prochain
le territoire entre sept-îles et
schefferville devrait être irriguée par
le wifi un changement radical alors que
le signal cellulaire est aujourd'hui
inexistants nouvel outil qui pourrait
permettre aux jeunes de retourner
peut-être dans le territoire de
développer le tourisme d'aventuré de
concevoir des applications pour mieux
gérer le caribou toutes ces possibilités
ouvertes grâce au temps pour moi car ça
c'est de prouver quand tu es capable
james bérubé est un aspect pis de
kawawachikamach qu'à 15 km de
schefferville qui dirige les opérations
de chez weight
prenez les propriétaires les trois
conseils il se travaille bien ensemble
nos employés ils sont les trois nations
en et même des employés des autres
nations c'est au québec puis garde oui
j'ai ouvert à sal
je voyais la petite pelouse le petit
parc en arrière travail ou consultent
pas qu'est ce que je fais c'est en
voyant la réserve d'un trou c'était
complètement différent et en hauteur des
locomotives puis je vois le territoire
conclut caustique
un pur hasard tu m'étonnes volant
s'appelle comme le trait il est aussi
mécaniciens de locomotive
il rappelle que dans les années 50 on
interdisait aux in ou de monter dans le
train qui passait sur leur territoire à
trois jours d'un train de tout ce manque
un autre hacker mana et rapide
et est ce que je comprends qu'un mac
sapeurs étaient frustrés maintenant je
vois bien que c'est le jour et la nuit
on interdit d'embarquer à bord dc10 qui
tarde barque
ce fut la même chose une douce revanche
signé twitter
[Musique]